stepan coo beef and johannes gun will
sign agreement between the governments
of Ukraine and the European Commission
on the financing of the action
EU anti-corruption initiative in Ukraine
phase 2
Stefan koubek and Johannes Kahn will
sign the agreement between the
governments of Ukraine and the European
Commission on the financing of the
action support to civil society and
culture Stepan coup beef and Johannes
Han will sign the addendum number 1
between the government of Ukraine and
the European Commission acting on behalf
of the European Union to the finance and
Agreement EU support to the east of
Ukraine
[Applause]
now we invite energy Zuko Vice Prime
Minister of Ukraine Minister for
regional development building housing
and communal services of Ukraine and
Johannes an Commissioner for European
neighbourhood policy and enlargement
negotiations who will sign the agreement
between the government of Ukraine and
the European Commission on the financing
of the action you lead with Europe
Ukraine local empowerment accountability
and Development Program phase two
our signing ceremony is concluded
the last time now we invite the
presidents of Ukraine to make a
statement can I be okay
sunlen dear mr. president here present
to skunker dear ladies and gentlemen
it's a great honor for me to welcome the
President of the European Council Donald
Tusk and President of the European
Commission jean-claude Juncker I
representative of the Union for Foreign
Affairs of security policy in my
civilian commission for the community
need and european commissioner johannes
on on the 21st summits ukraine EU we can
give a hand of applause to our dear
guests today's meeting is really the
meeting of partners and friends who
share common democratic values starting
from in 1997 this is the 21st summit all
together but the first one for me
personally people say that the newbies
are lucky and my team and i are ready to
act fast and very effectively so
possibly the 21st summit well could be
the last one because Ukraine could
become the inseparable part of Europe
today we have made a summary of power
relations but most of the time we were
discussing plans and priorities for the
future this future is not possible
without peace and Ukraine yesterday
together with president tools we visited
on bus particularly stomates America and
it's ashamed that the delegations of
some of the countries from the
Parliamentary Assembly of the Council of
Europe were not there with us I am sure
that it could be very very useful for
them so if anyone has any doubts any
questions or any kind of doubts as to
continuation of sanctions I can invite
all of them to Donna bus to show how
much trouble this war has created for us
and we really want to stop this war
and we're really wants to bring back
peace to Ukraine but this can only be
done with consolidated weapon and that
is diplomacy I was happy to hear from
our European friends today that their
position on the behavior of them the
conduct of the Russian Federation is
clear and unchanged sectoral and Crimean
chains sanctions will continue for the
next 12 and 6 months respectively please
you do not think that sanctions are is
my favorite warrant my favorite word is
peace and sanctioned policy is the last
civilized tool to achieve peace it has
to continue until the full completion of
the Minsk agreements the reinstatement
of sovereignty and territorial integrity
of Ukraine I said I spoke about this
before but I cannot get I will not get
tired to repeat that when our partners
are saying that do not forget that we're
losing money and our response is very
simple do not forget that we are losing
territories and we are losing people
every day going back to our trip to
stanitsa luganskaya I would like to note
that the removal of force has happened
there on both sides and now we're
waiting to see the the the removal of
concrete structures to bring you the
bridge we are moving towards this
ceasefire sustainable ceasefire not it's
not happening as fast as we'd like
because we're basically working the
minefield
in every sense of the word and ahead
we're facing a lot of work ahead to
rebuild Donbass and I'm grateful for to
the European Union for a number of
infrastructural projects that improved
the life of people in Donbass including
the efforts in the Indian are
liberated territories specifically in
the Azov sea region which continues to
suffer from the economic blockade of the
Azov sea we are discussing all these
matters on the Investment Forum on the
rebuilding of infrastructure of Don bus
which were planned to host in Mariupol
in September I and it all forum meetings
international meetings I'm inviting all
investors to attend the forum both
Ukrainian and its national investors we
were thinking about the achievements of
the recent years including the deep and
visa-free regime decentralization
transparent procurement but I believe
that this was just a starter for Ukraine
the most complex changes the most
complicated changes are still ahead and
Ukrainians are tired of waiting to see
them happen
the most important part is overcoming
corruption in the short time that I'm in
office we already have some achievements
we have D blocked international
cooperation between National
anti-corruption Bureau with
international anti-corruption bodies
another positive point is abolition of
electronic declarations for
anti-corruption activists we are also
preparing for full-fledged launch of the
high anti-corruption court the last
obstacle on this path was the absence of
necessary premises for this Authority
and this problem has been resolved on
the 5th of September this year this
Court will start looking into corruption
cases and then welcome you all and it's
located on the victory Avenue and this
is very symbolic because we're
interested not in fighting against
corruption but in winning a decisive
victory over corruption all of these are
little victories with our arms tired we
need to reboot the whole anti-corruption
system the worth of the work
specifically of the National
anti-corruption Commission and we
believe that the new law will
helped us work on the overcoming
corruption in Ukraine I'm grateful to
the European Union that is prepared to
support us including ready financial
support in this matter in the recent
years we have continuously heard that we
only need the political will to make it
happen and I have this well and some
people may not have the will to do as
they please for some time I'm not trying
to intimidate anyone but I know how much
the European partners are tired to
allocate funds on the mythical fight
against corruption very soon will we'll
be asking not for the money but for the
extradition of escaped stop corruption
errs I assured our European partners
that our position on all other reforms
of Ukraine is identical to share the
wing of economy establishment of
independent court overcoming monopolies
fighting against readership and
smuggling and tomorrow I am signing
respective decrees about that the income
leads to decentralization and
strengthening of civil society are also
important parts of it we have signed
five agreements that will facilitate
these reforms in Ukraine Benjamin
Franklin said that time is money and our
current problems include both the first
and the second components both with we
have problems with both time and money
and in order to establish positive
changes we want to move very fast today
we have also discussed trade relations
and we pointed out that the trade
between Ukraine and EU continues growing
this process is facilitated by deep and
comprehensive free trade area agreement
which is part of the association
agreement and so we should not stop the
or growth the better and I'm not talking
about me I'm talking about our economic
indicators my perspective the agreement
should be a flexible - that would be in
compliance with more than reality of our
relations and mainly the potential of
Ukraine that's why I offered to partners
to start the joint assessment of the
agreement implementation to achieve a
new level the level that would be in the
interests of Ukrainian European business
as well as in the interests of our
consumers meanwhile will be efficiently
using all available possibilities we are
keen on having further the sectoral
integration of Ukrainian market and the
EU markets that's energy digital market
justice customs and trade facilitation
I appreciate the readiness of the
European partners to allocate their
second tranche of the fourth program of
micro financial assistance to Ukraine
with 500 million euro to conclude what
we say that their relationship between
Ukraine and the EU is not just
partnership political association or
economic integration that we are friends
and we enjoy open frank
sometimes emotionally-charged but every
time that's an honest and friendly
dialogue about our joint future
geographical Ukraine is the center of
Europe and I will do my best for Ukraine
to become this Center economically and
in terms of the mindset we have a new
president in the country soon we'll have
a new Parliament in the country and
we'll have a new government in the
country and that means we'll have a new
chance thank you why the President of
the European Council donor to school
Thank You mr. president thank you very
much good afternoon today we held our
first you Ukraine summit with President
Zelaya
it followed our first meeting in early
June and it was an excellent summit that
allow us to even further improve the
partnership and friendship between
Ukraine and the European Union this is
also reflected in the joint statement
that we agreed today our partnership is
built on the association agreement which
is the most comprehensive agreement that
the US with any country it provides the
framework for a continuing political
association and economic integration
today we discussed how to make full use
of its potential for the benefit of our
citizens and businesses president
Juncker will speak more now economic and
energy cooperation so that means that
once again confirmed the --use
unwavering support for Ukraine's
territorial integrity sovereignty and
independence we do not and will not
recognize the illegal annexation of
Crimea and Sevastopol by Russia only a
few days ago the EU unanimously extended
the economic sanctions against Russia
for another six months
the sanctions will remain in place until
the Minsk agreements are fully
implemented the June European Council
also called on Russia to release without
end
the delay the detained 24 Ukrainian
servicemen and ensure unhindered and
free passage to and from the other sea
we condemned the Russian measures and
titling Ukrainian citizens of the area
of currently not under the control of
the government to apply for Russian
citizenship in a simplified manner the
France counter to the Minsk agreement
and we stand ready to consider further
options including non recognition of
such Russian passports yesterday I
visited eastern Ukraine to witness
firsthand the situation at the line of
contact it is clear that Minsk
agreements need more than ever before to
be implemented by all sides Russia has a
particular responsibility in this regard
today we reaffirmed our full support for
the diplomatic efforts in the Normandy
format the OSCE and trilateral contact
group to find a peaceful solution that
respects Ukraine's territorial integrity
and sovereignty during my visit
yesterday I saw the disengagement of
forces near stencil high schoo this
encouraging step now needs to be further
strengthened we expect Russia to make
full use of its considerable influence
over the separatists to make this
possible but I also witnessed the
critical situation in which people
affected by conflict leave the EU
continues to support the efforts
to alleviate the suffering that I saw
hand-in-hand with RC UN agencies as well
as international NGOs that you also
stand ready to support reconstruction
once the Minsk agreements are
implemented at our last two summits I
mentioned all extensive in December he
won the Sahara prize which the European
Parliament award to those who have
dedicated their life to the defense of
human rights and freedom of thought
unfortunately College is still
imprisoned I renew our call to Russia to
relieve him and all illegally detained
Ukrainians in Russia and the Crimean
Peninsula thank you in given now
statement by the president of the
European Commission jean-claude Juncker
mr. president ladies and gentlemen I'm
delighted to be back here in Kiev the
city I have known for decades but that I
keep with rediscovering with the same
joy as the very first time we were happy
to host the new president in Brussels
weeks ago he took the initiative to
organize his first trip outside the
country to Brussels we were welcomed
this initiative the new president mr.
szalinski starting his term at the time
when relations between Ukraine and
European Union are the best I can
remember I said this as someone who has
been there from the very start as
co-chair of our first summit in Kiev
between Ukraine and you will be noon on
the 5th of September 1997 11 o'clock in
the morning this is now the 21st summit
we have together it's your first it's
our last but having seen it I can
honestly say that we have made more
progress together in the last years
since the Maidan revolution than we did
into two decades before thanks to the
great sacrifices made by the great
Ukrainian people we have come a long way
and I'm proud to be able to say that we
have supported you every step of the way
our partnership is one of mutual
solidarity and friendship that's why we
are backing that solidarity up with
concrete support notably for the other
sea region so affected by ongoing
conflict and by in fact unacceptable
tensions due to behavior of Russia I'm
happy to announce today a new package of
measures in support to the other sea
region which includes measures to
rehabilitate he infrastructure in
Mariupol and castle new financing in
local currency for small and
medium-sized enterprises in the which
property work is also launched on rain
until markets paving the way for the
Loehmann's of over 450 million euros
from financial institutions we have also
witnessed today the signature of new
agreements for projects worth 119
million euros to further boost Ukraine's
efforts to reform continued
decentralization fight corruption and
support civil society mr. president
Madame Monsieur in European to the
present oh I see in fact we have to be
proud by Ukraine at our partnership
respectively the you and other financial
institutions have allocated more than 15
billion euro to support of the reforms
in Ukraine they have been doing that a
since 2014 that brings our people close
visa-free regime assisted and
contributed to that that has always been
on the agenda of the European Commission
starting June 1 2017 around 3 million of
visits we are conducted by Ukrainians to
the EU member states for this particular
reason we would like to enhance the
engagement the engagement of Ukraine in
erasmus+ programme Ukraine has been
already an active partner there more
than 7000 Ukrainian students have
already participated in the program that
includes enterpreneurs as well
cooperation thanks to the free trade
agreement Ukraine can facilitate its
growth growth and see more progress in
various areas after the agreement
agreements came into effect with the
growth of 49 percent the partnership is
effective and working in my previous
career when I was the president in my
country and I was the president of the
European Commission every time we spoke
about corruption it was the focus of all
our discussions what I want to do this
time I went to see Ukraine that has a
new president could undertake or steps
and will eliminate corruption in Ukraine
because people of Ukraine have high
expectations they are determined to make
this happen
that's the nation that deserves to be
without any corruption thank you we
appreciate the attention on the part of
media to the 21st summit
although we are behind the time but we
have some time for Q and a so the
president's amidst
Tusker Janka and jocelyn scale ready to
answer your questions let's start with
the Ukrainian media I journalists in
white jacket Alexandre Romano come over
to you mr. Zaleski you spoke about that
already that's Easter's than the Logans
because the nature and build in the
bridge Russian propaganda will use
different methods for the bridge not to
be constructed do you have any timeframe
for the project to be completed and
implemented are you going to cut
European partners engaged not only
financially but as the ones that would
secure some guarantees and how important
is the project for Ukraine thank you
thank you for your question I believe
that such answering this question I
think President to school add to that we
were there together yesterday as to
bridge reconstruction that was one of
the items on the Minsk agreement
agreement it was pulled out of the
troops we pulled out our respective
troops that was done by both parties and
then we suggested here constructing this
bridge we have money in the budget
that's a proposal clear pian partners
that we have to we don't need anything
else but for the bridge to be
constructed it is very important for the
other side to dismantle a concrete
installations and structures as you
remember they said that technically they
will need 810 days to do that honestly
speaking we are ready to do that quickly
in the course of two three days but
these are two for all processes that's
what we agreed upon I haven't seen what
I saw there my proposal is we are not
going to wait for a long time we don't
have time to wait you know what's
happening to people there people are
crying in presidentís could confirm that
people did request this to happen one
elderly lady came up to me and said
Volodya you know I am a person with
disability I walk with a stick that's
the lady that is over 70 and she was
pleading me to do that so we are going
to wait for another week maximum 8 days
unless we see dismantling conducted by
the other side we'll start constructing
the bridge we are ready to do that
civilians can do that servicemen
military can to do that they are not
entitled to do that we have the ideas
how to do that we promised people that
the bridge will be constructed within 1
months that's going to be done is it
okay I am NOT talking too long
they another thing that we saw there
from the point where the bridge is to be
constructed to government controlled
area it takes but the distance is around
to one kilometer and people have to walk
that and that adds complexity to the
situation mr. tusk and I were there and
my idea was like that yeah talked to the
new hatoful lugansk oblast
administration and our team there and
the idea is to have electric cars and
shuttle buses to take people there we
saw a lot of people walking there with
the cases these are young people they
live in in Ukraine they were visiting
their parents on the other side and the
other way around so we want to have this
service to write them through so we are
going to more foster we want to make
sure that Miss agreement is implemented
but we want to move faster than
diplomats thank you
just on reflection its
first of all I really appreciate the
free thinking of mr. president thank you
very much my hopes may be a little bit
more limited when it comes to the other
side on on the contact line I saw that
our side sorry but president allow me
allowed me to use this hour on our side
the Ukraine has fulfilled all the
obligation when it comes to this idea of
this engagement on the other side they
did this is why
my hopes limited of course this is a
question of trust it's a full I think
it's for all of us it's something very
difficult to trust them when it comes to
this kind of proposals and processes
like disengagement but maybe this is the
only way to test they will touch the VMO
video thank you for this so let's
suggest the words to a pouring media and
maybe a Christopher Miller at Radio
Liberty yes yes Chris yes mix we are
ready to French language really okay
I'll ask in English okay okay you've
taken a more hearts and minds approach
to the conflict then your predecessor
you were in stanitsa luganskaya and you
have talked a lot about fixing the
bridge but are you prepared to take
other steps like lifting the economic
blockade and perhaps perhaps making it a
little bit easier for Ukrainians on the
other side of the contact line to
receive their pensions on the government
control side of the contact line
secondly the u.s. embassy said yesterday
that Ukraine has officially requested to
buy weapons from the US can you say
which weapons in particular Ukraine
would like to buy and for the other
presidents on either side of you you you
said today that again you you reiterated
your demands for Russia to release
Ukrainian captives in the 24 sailors
held held captive by Russia but Russia
has not listened to you up to this point
at what point is the EU prepared to to
take more stronger measures to to force
Russia to
these demands jocke reaction thank you
if I may answer first unless the
presents are don't mind I'd like to say
which steps we have proposed to continue
the Minsk agreements and to resolve the
matter of ceasefire and disengagement we
would like to stop this war in the
shortest time we offer the opportunity
on getting the pensions people were
complaining a lot yesterday that a
person can only get their pension within
one month within 60 days they can only
get a pension for 60 days and we have
offered the following step now let us
expand this opportunity for the people
to be people to be humans we gave them a
term of one year for which they can
receive their pensions but I very much
hope that we won't have this form within
a year's time people were also
complaining that a lot of food products
cannot be transported to the other side
they cannot carry them they cannot bring
them to the other side we have a simple
proposal here they have to have a list
of products or items that they cannot
carry across the line this is very easy
to do that and we should not have a
prohibitive list instead this will make
life much easier for the people on the
other side because they're not playing
political games they live in Ukraine and
there's nothing they can do because
their parents for example are in a
difficult situation when they do not
want to move to Ukraine to the
Ukrainian territories to the territories
controlled by us the matter of economic
blockades
I don't want to be misunderstood here
you know that all of that is possible
we're discussing this in Minsk
I remember how media read misinterpreted
president ex President Kuchma
we said that everything can be done but
then please bring us back well
nationalized or whatever other work you
may use to illegally nationalized our
enterprise enterprises that are
allocated on temporarily occupied
territories and men in Minsk we are also
discussing the matter of exchange of
prisoners of war the lists of both
parties do not match they're showing us
the lists that there's less which
include less people then there are
actually there without the people whom
we know we're there we want to stop the
war and we hope to find a solution and
we hope to achieve progress in the
exchange of prison prisoners of war as
well in the soonest possible time on the
agreements with the US right and this
was your second question if you don't
mind I cannot disclose this matter for
now time will come thank you sanctions
against Russia if I remember well the
three weeks ago and it's very unlikely
that we will decide on the new sanctions
in in the short-term perspective it
mr. you can okay okay
one more question Interfax bite majora
mandala shank from on the shank winter
Fox Ukraine please hello
if I may ask this question president of
European Commission mr. Chekov each
announced that there will be trilateral
guests discussions or guest trends of
discussions what kind of results do you
expect from these negotiations another
question to president zelanski with the
upcoming parliamentary elections there
are lots of candidates with very similar
names with the last name similar to
yours how do you see this from
technology that can distorts the choice
of the citizens well you said that this
question is not very serious but I know
that this is I mean the second part of
your question is pretty complex there's
lots of copies of parties the servicemen
of the people I cannot promote my party
as a president I cannot promote the
campaign of the servicemen of the people
political party I understand that there
are lots of copies of this party
particularly in the majority system I
know the the guys from the party of the
servicemen of the people address the
court and the Electoral Commission on
this matter but there's no answer yet I
will not influence the Central Electoral
Commission or the courts on this matter
about what I would very much like the
people well when they make their choice
so that the people reads the lists
carefully what is the party to make sure
that they're looking at the political
party servicemen of the people but I
cannot promote the party in any way as
to mr. chef kovitch I did have a
discussion with him about the new
contracts you know that we have a
certain time line we should continue
with the contract and I know that this
discussion should continue in December
but this is the matter of energy
security of Ukraine I made a statement
about my position and about my team's
position that we do want to sit down at
the negotiation table
in September already and we want to
resolve the matter and I think we can
make it thank you
I think that the functional relationship
between Ukraine European Union and
Russia is in interest of all sides as
you rightly said vice presidents Africa
which stands ready to help to find the
solution before the end of this year I
have to add what we always said that the
unbundling of natural gas is essential
it is in the interest of all Ukraine
citizens for the sector to be more
transparent and more competitive we hope
this will happen before the end of this
year
Yoko's up with that thank you for your
questions I think that's it we're really
out of time thank you very much that was
important to ask questions
you
[Music]
you